you know live chat
i see i got it flashed up well good
morning everybody
good morning to members of the public
watching this meeting on youtube
good morning to all the committee
members and the officers
and to start with i'll ask that all the
members of the committee their names are
read out and they
say who they are and what ward to
represent
so uh who's doing
krusty are you doing there with me are
you good mark for this meeting or
yeah or mary yes it's mary mary all
right mary if you
and are you ready yeah yeah council
about him
yeah i'm here i'm richard about and i
represent um
heartland councillor brown
yes good morning everybody i represent
um
great torrington ward and margaret brown
thank you
council christie good morning my name is
peter christie i represent biddeford
north
councillor craigie good morning
everybody
i represent um easter water the
different east
councillor leather good morning
everybody
uh chris leather and i represent
northern ward
councillor lock good morning my name is
rosary lock and i represent the ward
of two rivers and three laws
cancelled mcgough good morning my name
is derek mcguff and i represent the
biddeford northward
councilor watson oh good morning yeah
pete watson i represent broadhead
councillor wiseman hello richard wiseman
i represent the chevier and langtry ward
and would the officers who are present
like to introduce themselves
and say they are please
good morning members and members of the
public my name is sean harrington and
i'm the development manager
at our district council
good morning i'm stacy dory i'm head of
legal and governance at toronto district
council
good morning everyone my name is james
jackson i'm the development management
team leader at the council
morning chris evely planning officer
good morning debbie fuller planning
officer
and that's everybody i think in it
and we've got mary brownish taking the
minutes of this meeting for us
okay thanks uh i'll move on to the
agenda then
uh but before i do that i better read
out about virtual meetings we've always
always got to read this out at these
meetings i'd like to welcome everybody
to this virtual meeting of the plans
committee on the
5th of november i'll just go through
some basic rules
for this meeting at the start of the
meeting
we will mute all microphones except for
mine please leave all microphones muted
unless you're asked
by me to speak
residents who want to exercise this
right have been asked
to register in advance and also they've
had the operation
option of sending in a statement to be
read out by the
officer or if they've been they've been
sent a link
to the to temporarily join the meeting
to speak in person
we've got one two three four five
six people registered to speak to the
various planet planning applications
this morning
to indicate to me that you would like to
speak or propose a second emotion
please press the raise hand symbol
in the participants menu on your screen
these are shown on my screen in the
order that they are pressed
and i'll deal with them in the order
giving the appropriate officer
or counsellor the opportunity to answer
in between where necessary i will also
return to the counsellor
to check that they're happy with the
response
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
virtual meetings
all votes will be cast via a verbal
recorded vote
and names will be read out in
alphabetical order
please state your vote clearly and
slowly when your name is read out
unmuting and muting your microphone as
necessary
and just a reminder to everybody that is
been this meeting
to ensure full transparency with
democratic process
this meeting is being live streamed on
the council's youtube channel
i ask you all to be patient during this
meeting and especially with me because
if i forget something in and out and to
understand that the processes
and advice may take a little longer than
usual
when we've done the introductions now so
i'll go to the agenda then the first
item on the agenda is apologies
but i think we've got a full compliment
this morning
so that's correct yeah we have so i'll
move on to item two on the agenda
which is the minutes of our previous
meeting which is on pages
five to nine and that's for the
the meeting so i can get to the page
for the meeting held on thursday the 1st
of
october
if somebody would like to move those
minutes
and it's a little locker you're moving
those minutes
your music cancel a lot yeah
i'll i'll move the minute
thank you councillor locke thank you
councillor watson
i moved to the vote then may if you take
the vote on those minutes please
yes chair councillor bowton at four
cancer brown board
council christie
councillor craigie four
or council watson
or council wiseman four
okay unanimous thank you mary
right item three on the agenda
is declaration of interest members with
interest to declare should refer to the
agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the items being considered
elected members of devon county council
and town and parish councils who've
considered
a planning application by virtue of
their membership of that council
hold a personal interest and are deemed
to have considered the application
separately
and the expressed views of that council
do not bind the members concerned
who considered the application afresh
item four on the agenda is agreements
between parts one and two there is no
part two
five on the agenda is urgent matters
i've nothing urgent i don't know if
sean harrington has anything
urgent councillor christie you've got
your hands up
yes um i don't know if members have
noticed that there is an application or
for a field in biddeford for 290 houses
i actually did email sean
asking would this automatically come to
this planning committee
because we did vote against it last time
and i was told it has to be called in
can i ask what what are the parameters
for officers to bring it
straight to the planning committee
without a member having to call it in
sean would you like to answer council
chrisley please yeah of course chair uh
thank you councillor christie
um the constitution states that um it
doesn't state that major applications uh
would automatically go
to community um they would have to be
called in by the ward member or members
of uh plans committee there is a element
of discretion
for the development manager myself to
call applications into committee
if there was strategic importance or
likely to be contentious
with this application like say has been
at um
or an early application has been at
plans committee previously
which was called in by a member at that
time
and again i'd expect this application to
be called in if mems have concerns about
it
thank you thank you sean
uh right no more origin matters so i'll
move on to
item six which is future site visits
well we don't know of any
currently we've been holding virtual
site visits
which have been going very well um
item seven on the agenda is public
petition participation
we've got one two three four five
six speakers for the three applications
this morning
um and
i'll give the details now because that
says on the agenda to give the details
the order of speakers is as follows
first the planning officer
will give their presentation on the
application and then any town or parish
councillor
who wishes to speak either for against
the application
have the opportunity to speak
and then up to two public speakers who
wish to speak against
an application they'll get three minutes
each
and then there's two public speakers who
want to support the application and they
get three minutes each
and the last speaker of all is always
the torres district council
ward member um in whose ward the
application falls
and there's no time limit for the board
member giving their
view on an application so
as we get the applications we've got for
the first one which is a hunt show
application we've got
philip hackett down as a member of the
public to speak in support
dr simon harvey to support a member of
the public
for this second application at milton
gamerill we've got councillor ken
james speaking as ward member
for the apple door application ithaca
we've got a wendy braxton speaking
member of the public speaking
against we've got dave and lindsey
inwood
they are the applicants obviously
they're speaking in support
and then we have caroline short speaking
in support
she's the agent and they're the speakers
listed this morning
right we'll move on then to item eight
which is the planning applications
and the first one on our agenda 8a
is a site that landed grid reference
uh hampshire the grid reference given
that
full application the erection of four
holiday lodges and
christian evil in the planning officer
will give the presentation on this
thanks chris thank you chair um
so as um chairman points out excuse me
i did have my
just to declare an interest this
application is in my ward
i called it initially when i first saw
it but i come to this
meeting with a clear and open mind thank
you thank you councillor
right chris right on okay so it's
for the erection of four holiday lodges
as you say
landed grid reference um shown there i
won't repeat it
there is an update and the applicants
have submitted a letter from an
accountant
giving us summary invoice and have
requested that members be updated
the accounts show the site is in receipt
of an annual woodland grant and rpa
grant for the woodland area alongside
the applicant's pension
the accountant's notes this entitles
them to a farmer rate
however this is for country purposes not
planning
um as you see in the office report we do
not consider the site agricultural and
if anything
the accounts prove that there's no
agricultural activities on the site
as per the officer report it's solely
used for equestrian and forestry
purposes
this is a location planner of the site
you can see
the site in the center there in the
paddock
area to the top left hand
corner of the site the applicant runs uh
commercial stables
specializing in the training of
resources
and the site is surrounded by woodlands
um this is a site plan it shows that
there'd be four holiday lodges located
um along the high point in the field and
accessed by
existing access tracks through the
woodland
this is an old photo of the site it
shows uh
for a location point of view huntsville
cross in the bottom right hand corner
most people will know where that is
and then the applicant's commercial
sales in the top left hand corner
and somewhere in between you will see
the application site
amongst woodland this is the view from
the site entrance
as you come off the highway looking west
and likewise looking east and then from
the other side of this
gateway that's going into the existing
forestry access tracks
again moving through the forestry access
tracks
it looked like this and then just at the
bottom of this one
that's where it opens out into the
opening and field
this is a view from inside the forestry
gate entering
the paddock you can see there's long
distance views it wasn't the greatest
day however it does have fairly
spectacular views
uh this is looking north along where
the cabins will be sited along this area
here
and this is looking is that gone
i don't know what's wrong with the
presentation but
okay well let's scrap looking south
there's some woodland but it's
no longer there so this is the front
elevation
side elevation
side elevation
and rear elevation you can see there's a
two-story log cabin appearance
floor plan four bedroom with a terrace
upstairs and in the floor plan again
with terrace
and an example i suspect it looks pretty
much exactly the same as that looking at
the floor plans etc
uh these are the main plan
considerations and if you've read my
report which i hope you will have you
see that i'm recommending
refusal due to the proposal being
unjustified this
countryside location and causing
landscape harm
and final slide you can see recommended
for refusal and recorded vote to be
taken
so thank you chair i will pass back to
you to introduce the speakers
thanks uh chris could you just go back
to that picture you had of
it the aerial view of the site
at the start yep and just on my way it's
just running a little bit slowly so
you'll have to um
you'll have to bear with me while i
flick
okay that's the one could you can you
tell me to the right hand
top right hand corner that large
industrial site
um do you know who's that site is
there's loris park that's a lot of
industrial activity on that site
so this is um the land in the
applicant's ownership so you can see it
runs in
a blue line relatively tight to the
woodland
yeah going around there so that wouldn't
appear to be from this
site location plan within the
applicant's ownership
right if you can put that photograph
back please
there yeah so the boundary the boundary
of this application site the blue line
is almost up to that industrial area
there that
comes off the main torrington to
barnstable road
yeah it it certainly appears that way
all that woodland there belongs
is in the blue line yeah
yeah okay yeah now i have a question now
because
i think i don't know if officers have
had this we
committee members have had a letter from
the applicant stating that this is an
agricultural holding
and it's registered and there's a number
given one zero one five four
zero zero two two an agricultural
holding
and that it is a 127 acre farm
and they go on to say that they've spare
stables
and an american bomb which has regularly
been used for lambing and chickens
so i i've been confused whether this is
in aggregate cultural holding or not
since reading that
okay chad um should we discuss do you
want to discuss
this um after the speakers or before
it's entirely up to you
well i just would like a bit of
clarification on is it an agricultural
holding
to say applicant claims because in the
report it says
it's not an agricultural holding but it
is a forestry
you know it's it's rather confusing
really
yeah council raised a hand cancel a lot
it will go to the speakers then and
maybe we'll we'll come to an answer
during this and thanks council a lot
yeah i was going to say when i um speak
on
this application i am going to cover
that point about agriculture and
agriculture
holdings right council lock if you want
to
if you want to lead the discussion on
this application then
well you have not the public speakers
yeah oh i beg your pardon yeah
sorry there you anywhere i did ask
at the start to bear with me right thank
you councillor
our first public speaker is um
philipp hackey down as a member of the
public but he's a torres district
councillor
um and i see that you are present
councillor hackett
yes good morning chair thank you um are
you hearing me
yes we can hear clearly right thank you
very much
i've been associated with tony newcomb
for four years
as a rider and taking his horses racing
i have ridden the five miles of tracks
laid out in the tranquil woodlands
which are full of tame deer and foxes
which share the habitat with you
i have been fortunate to ride the gallop
even canter with a buzzard flying upside
my shoulder
and have had to take evasive action when
a deer or a fox
jumps out in front of you this
is a green oasis well named as foxtown
woods
and cherished by local walkers
biddeford bay and lundy set out in the
silvery sea lie before you
the view is from the highest point of
the biosphere
a panorama unsurpassed
this woodland of a hundred thousand
trees
planted 20 years ago as part of the farm
diversification policy is now scheduled
for harvesting
to recoup that investment
tony is loath to cut down the trees
fortunately
an owner invested in this plan to
develop the limited number
of luxury holiday lodges
a development designed designed to
attract
higher spending tourists wishing to wake
up
touching nature and to share the
tranquility of the habitat
enriched by the enveloping wildlife
not one tree will be removed
there is a financial safety net to the
investment
as the timber value underwrites the
asset
the act of tree felling does not require
planning permission
detrimentally it will leave a lasting
scar
on this most prominent landscape
situated below
huntshore radiomast the animals may move
on
the scar will be visible and lasting
this application provides sustainable
green alternative
to a council which is declared a climate
emergency
it will provide year-round sustainable
tourism
supported by policy st07 and
st-13 it preserves
and enhances the environmental asset
compliant with policy st-14
creating employment supported by policy
st 11.
it is compliant with farm
diversification policy dm-15
this is preferable to the trees going
exposing that industrial unit
that is off the site owned by the
applicant
and the business will be wound up and
the 127
acre farm will be sold on
committee this application before you
supports our tourist
objectives creates jobs and enhances
our economy i urge you
to approve this application thank you
very much chair thank you committee
thank you
our second uh speaker in support is dr
simon harvey if he's present
no chair he's not present
right well that's the end of public
speakers for this application so
we'll go to the committee members
neither chair um
the the speaker has sent in something
to sean harrington to be read out in his
absence if this was to happen
is that correct sean
sorry chair yes i did have my uh my hand
up so um
yes i do have a statement uh in the
absence of
dr simon harvey if you're happy for me
to read that out yeah fine
yes okay and i'll start
mr chairman members of the planning
committee thank you for affording the
opportunity to have some small input to
your meeting
having visited the northern devon
biosphere for a number of years i have
personally become aware of this complete
lack of up-market lodge accommodation in
the entire district
which which as an area appears primarily
centered on tourist accommodation
in the thin coastal ribbon or westwood
hill in biddyford which has become
saturated
more so i have noted a lack of this
accommodation more in torridge than
north devon
although both councils operate off the
same local plan
as a businessman an entrepreneur running
four businesses including environmental
consultancy
employing over 60 qualified engineers i
am acutely aware of environmental
impacts
having performed a huge project for the
hs2 projects
in the capital i can readily see an
opportunity to develop
luxury lodges on this site due to
enormous potential to draw in high-end
tourists
who wish to experience something
different to the saturated market of
bucket and spade holidays
there is far more to tourists than this
you have lovely lovely rural countryside
you have nature experiences that i and
my family would like to visit and
explore from locations such as this
application site
as a keen investor i can see how all of
local attractions can be marketed and
promoted
in researching turrets i have come
across north 11 plus and i've seen our
full council agenda from last monday's
meeting
i see that you're proposing to create a
destination management organization
which stresses the importance of tourism
to north devon
it lays out how terrorist is
characterized by smes and how the
council wishes
to increase the tourism season how you
wish to spread the tourism activity
within the area
the balance of volume and value the
priorities towards staying against
day visitors it is all on page 147 of
the full council agenda
planning committee i am asking for you
to back your own council's policy
aspirations
as an investor this is a safe bet for me
i can develop the site to bring in the
high-speed spending tourists
who have money to spend at your quality
restaurants and bespoke shops
obviously i do have a full back position
the cutting down of the trees and the
farm being sold
but what a waste of an opportunity for
both torrid and the whole community
for the above reasons i sincerely hope
that you'll support your own aspirations
and support this application
dr s p hargreaves thank you chair
thank you sean right that is the end of
public's contribution so
i think council lot wants to speak first
on this councillor locke
yeah certainly um the officer claims
that this is not agricultural
yet if you look at the definite
definition of agriculture there are
six branches of agriculture agronomy
horgi forestry animal husbandry
fishery science agricultural engineering
and home sciences
after 2001 the farm had a dairy herd
which was taken out with foot and mouth
as were several other dairy farms within
torridge
and to survive many had to find ways of
diversification
which is exactly what this applicant did
and the forests have a registered
agricultural holding number
and i note that the access tracks in the
forest which i mentioned in the offices
report
were given permission under an
application number followed by the
letters
agr which denotes agricultural activity
there's 95 acres of woodland 32 acres of
pasture which is used for sheep
yes and horses grazing but it's also cut
for fodder
um policy st 13 high quality
tourism development that promotes a
year-round industry
will be supported and tourism growers
should all
should be sustainable and st
13 also states that it should not damage
the natural or historic assets of
northern devon
my point on this one you don't know if
anything is sustainable until you've
actually tried it
and i do not consider these logics with
damage the natural or historic assets of
northern devon
uk tourism will be absolutely critical
to allowing our economy
economic recovery and many many more
people will be looking to stay in the uk
and this form of accommodation will be
vital to our recovery
these type of lodges will be for use all
year round
and they fit under tdc green tourism
policy
the lodges will have solar panels ground
source heat pumps
internal design details to minimize the
light pollution
and the business is built to meet the
requirements of unesco and the north
devon biosphere
and if you've got your mind's back to
laugh last month's committee meeting
and i know and appreciate that every
application on his own merits
the last points i mentioned were
absolutely praised and discussed
about the application for holiday lodges
at welcome
the m15 farm diversification i consider
it fits in with dean
the development will not detract
unreasonably from the amenities of the
occupiers of accommodation in this
vicinity and e there is no result of
unacceptable increase in traffic on the
approach roads
that will be detriment to the safety of
users of the highway
dm18 tourism accommodation points e and
f are relevant
and if you turn to the mppf
um 0.8 i think this application meets
both a
an economic objective and c an
environmental
objective as pointed out by councillor
hackett in his presentation
and point 83 of the mppf
supporting the prosperous rural economy
and that fits in with points a b c
um i will just finish then before i
listen to what other councils say
devon county highways have no objection
the parish council supported the
ejection
there are no letters of ejection and
there's one letter of support
and the environmental protection can i
just ask the officer
that the environmental protection
officer asked for the applicant to
review the daily flow calculation to the
satisfaction
to the satisfaction has any more
information be received on that chris
please
um no but i've been to site and um
i'm happy that it does comply with the
general binding rules
so um i i've liaised with matt um
and was formerly he hasn't removed
anything
and we're we're satisfied that in terms
of drainage the scheme is absolutely
fine
all right and my final point i mean on
page 18 the officer's refusal reason
i absolutely cannot agree with the
officer in the statement
in addition the proposal results in
landscape harm
by creating building clutter
i mean that these are top of the range
lodges in this remote and tranquil site
and no way should they be classed as
building clutter so i will finish my
presentation there
and wait to see what other committee
members have to say thank you
but i thought is that i fully support
this application
thank you councillor lock um chris
you've got a hand up
before i bring in councillor craig
thanks chad yeah that'd be great um so
in terms of and the definition of
agriculture in planning terms
um it's actually much more narrow than
the definition
uh which rose has given so point
uh paragraph 1.9 sets out the definition
of agriculture for planning
purposes which is uh defined in section
336 of the time country planning act
um and it it specifically excludes
forestry
unless that forestry is ancillary to an
agricultural purpose which in this case
it is not
so this site is a forestry site
and a commercial stables um the fact
that he has a holding number really
doesn't mean anything to punish um you
know and anyone can have
any field and have an agricultural
holding number
that doesn't mean anything for playing
purposes we simply look at section 336
of the act um so rosemary
um kindly pointed out last month's
committee um
with the one in welcome or heartland or
wherever it was it wasn't there
she's right in that each site is on its
own merits however that site is
um significantly different in that
they'll have
existing um tourism
at the site itself now
uh the key here is that every planning
application should be determined in
accordance with policy and you cannot
pick and choose
elements of the policy it has to comply
with the entire policy itself
um so our tourism policy for example
requires one of those three
points um which we we don't consider and
it complies with
um i'll let other speakers come in and
hopefully try and answer all the
questions as they come up
thank you chris councillor craigie
hello thank you chairman um
i'd like to support this application um
i do have some sort of personal
experience with the lodges that were
built at rutland
water in um in rutland um
because my mother lives up there and
there was a huge amount of people
um who were against them when they were
built
but now they've been up for quite a few
years people love them
and it's brought in a whole bird
watching community
which has helped the whole local economy
to thrive
once a year all the local
bed and breakfasts get full of uh bird
watchers
and it's a wonderful experience and it
gives a lot of town people the chance to
see
the woodlands and and the whole
countryside and
and it it you know the whole thing is
appreciated by everybody
so i i think that it's the the report is
rather negative about it i think it
could be they
they could be a really good asset to the
whole area
and i welcome people trying to
create something new and develop the
economy
and um you know put us on the map so
i really want to support it and i think
counselor lock has covered all the
the technical issues uh very well
and um i'd like to propose that we
support this
and give them every encouragement
thank you thank you councillor craig
councillor brown
thank you very much chair i do um agree
with the
previous speakers um i do know that
hunts your parish council
um do say as long as the woods remain
accessible to the public
and the noted points regarding trees and
hedges along with foul water drainages
changes are addressed as required
there's no apparent reason for the
parish council
to oppose so then they are in favor
chair um
i'd also like to say i think the design
is great
and we do know that we do need some more
um
i might say up across uh tourism
development
we haven't got much in this area a few
caravan sites
and i think that something new of this
design
will bring more people to the area lots
of lots of people out there will pay
extra money
for an experience like this so i think
it's um as long as the woodlands
don't get kept cut down i think none of
us want to see that
i would support also this application
thank you chair
thank you council brown before i bring
council watson in can i bring in
sean harrington please
thank you chair um i believe that that
was a
uh motion to approve from uh councillor
craigie earlier
before members discusses further i'd
just
like to remind members that
planning law states that plan permission
must be determined in accordance with
the development plan
unless material considering
considerations indicate otherwise
in the event that the plans committee is
minded to grant an application contrary
to officer recommendation
uh they must provide full conditions and
relative informatives
and a full statement of reasons for
approval um as to find the town country
planning uh general development
procedure order
um combined with relevant local plan and
local
and mp ppf uh policies and uh paragraphs
um so that should form part of that
motion and
members may wish to discuss that further
with
the officer's input and my input as well
if required thank you chair thank you
sean
uh right councillor watson thank you
chair
well thank you to uh rosemary rosemary
lock
i sat here all yesterday afternoon
writing out all this stuff
and she's just totally stole my thunder
and and i agree with the with ruth craig
i i also know rutland extremely well
uh especially brooklyn water uh and um
margaret brown and we should be looking
to
we should be looking to approve this
application because
i think it's in a fantastic place
and if the trees got i think there'd be
more complaints if the trees got
harvested
because it will be a blot a real blotch
on the landscape
uh with all that so i'll leave it to see
who else is wants to speak
before i make any decision
thank you councillor thank you chris
chris evelyn you've got your hand up
again
thank you um so just regards to the
trees um so there's
nothing preventing this application
coming forward and the trees being cut
down
and ultimately it isn't a policy
consideration so
um let's it's bad to use analogies but
let's say
taylor wimpy homes bought for us and
said we won't cut down these trees
if you let us build 300 homes it's
really it's not a plain policy
consideration
um you have to consider the policy and
what it says
the policy in this case is quite clear
in that it needs to be
either reusing or converting a building
um directly related to or compatible
with an existing tourism or leisure
attraction
or it needs to improve or diversify
existing tourism accommodation which
trafficking has so
um whilst there might you know i was
trying to crash can we not put a
protection order on the woodland
no not really no it's not
because it's forestry commission
woodland and it wouldn't be a reasonable
thing to do
um there's the the thing is woodland is
is meant to be cut down it's it's
designed
to differ there no so this so this is a
this is a forestry commission plant
plantation
which has a certain lifespan forestry
like agriculture
is a rural industry so that you know
that's a fact
and whether or not members of the public
et cetera
think this is a good idea or as
councillor craig and councillor brown
and and councillor watson pointed out
and they may
they may think it's a good idea etc but
the fact is you need to consider this in
accordance with what the policy actually
says
and i'd recommend going through the
policy points and considering it that
way
um there's not necessarily me being
negative
it's just we have to be consistent in
our decision making and one of the ways
we are consistent is to ensure that we
go through those policies and ensure
that it meets all those points thank you
thanks chris um councillor locke
i'll bring you in and then councilman
mcgoth
well following what council craig said i
will
recommend approval of this application
as it fits with policy
st13 dm 15 points d
and e and d m 18 e and f
and with regard to the mppf it meets the
economic and environmental objections
objectives and mppf 83
is also applicable so i will put those
reasons forward for approval
thank you uh council lot councillor
mcgoff
thank you mr chairman if council locks
propose not i will second that proposal
uh just a quick question uh mr chairman
as you just already alluded to there but
a tpl so on the
forestry thing itself um if it's like
likely to be approved
is there not some sort of condition we
could put on there obviously through the
biodiversity
decarbonization that should be within
our local plan going forward
can there not an officer answer that for
him please because we're going totally
against the biodiversity what we're
actually
trying to achieve going forward as a
council
thanks councilman mcguff sean do you
want to answer that
some of this as i look at the plan in
front of us now
some of this is natural woodland it's
not all planted forestry is it
yeah uh yeah thank you chad i think
there's a few
a few elements that i need to pick up on
um here
in relation to lee woodland um as the
officer correctly stated that woodland
is planted as a cro-op
which is dealt with under different
legislation as opposed to planning
legislation
i take uh councilman mcoff's point about
the
biodiversity of the scheme that may be
something that the officer that members
would like to
look at especially with regard to a net
gain which is required
as part of a development but we wouldn't
be able to
um i don't think that woodland uh would
be
suitable for a tree protection order um
given its character and its context of
that woodland
um and also i don't think it would meet
the tesla conditions to
condition the retention of that woodland
in relation to this particular
application
for tourism accommodation moving on to
councillor locke's motion council lock
mentions
policy dm 15 and i believe correct me if
i'm wrong
that it corded with element d and e of
dm15
uh dm15 is clear in that um in support
of the aircraft
sector proposals for from diversions
diversification schemes
will be supported where and it goes
through a b
c d and e it's not in ore
it needs to hit all of those elements as
opposed to just a couple of those
elements and if i just run through those
fully benefit of members
dm15a states the scalar development is
justified by the operational needs of
the enterprise
and will reinforce the viability of the
existing farm business
i the officer may correct me here but i
don't believe we have any evidence to
prove that that's
um that's uh complied with
um the the prospects of the release of
vacant buildings and user redundant
buildings on the site have been explored
fully and opportunities exhausted
well that that may be the case in this
instance um
and any sea any new buildings are sited
close to existing buildings and can be
satisfactorily assimilated to the
surrounding countryside
having regard to form design landform
landscaping special landscape qualities
and characters
whereas members can see from the plan on
the implantation in front of them
um i have doubts uh weberly sighting
so distinct and isolated from the
existing buildings can comply with that
section
of dm15 so again
understanding counselor looks motion
but the m15 means look at all these
elements and not just
a couple of those and that may members
may wish to discuss that
further thank you thank you
councillor watson oh yeah chair um
yeah i i understand where rose is coming
from and i understand where shaun is
coming from
but just think if we looked at it
sensibly
um four lodges four bedroom lodges
gonna cost quite a few thousand pounds
and the idea of them lodges is to have
the woodland i know what it's like
because at the back of me we've got 85
acres
and they've been in there and thinned it
out um
yeah they will cut it down eventually
um but then again uh sir william has got
no objection to that that's why
that's what it was put up for but i
think if he didn't want it cutting down
he would tell them that he didn't want
it cut him down
and if you put the lodges we we granted
this and then put the lodges up
and then decimated the woodland who
would want to go there anyway
i look at this as though this is for
people to go
and enjoy the woodland and and
and the wildlife i mean the wildlife
will disappear
so um i'm just looking at it in that
point of view but i agree but i actually
agree with what rose is saying
but with how we can approve it okay
and i would have i would have seconded
it had it not been for demo
thank you councillor watson councilman
goff
thank you mr chairman um just i'll let
you come back on page 15 of the report
uh 2.5 in the opinion of the planning
officer this proposal
does have the potential to cause harm to
the tranquility
and remoteness of the area by citing
four large structures away from any
other building
uh or prominent hillside location i mean
from the pictures
uh you know as you see from the pictures
you can't i've been to this site myself
um you can't really see it
unless you come with an area of you
and this this one find this but it's my
own personal opinion here that's what i
really find
mind-boggling sometimes you can't see
these lodges and i
agree with cancer watson that you know
you are protecting the forestry there
and it's so important for us to try and
protect this for the biodiversity and
say the wildlife triggers
etc going forward we're just
the um christian you you did allude to
the tower and country planning act
though
point something would you please read
that out to me
i'm not trying to prolong the meeting
but this is important to me to
understand
because as you can see you get three
different planners in the room
you could get three different opinions
you did allude to this um this policy
could you read that
to me please thoroughly obviously i i i
work for you for the experience of this
you know
i don't experience what you do with
planning it's just
no no problems counseling off so it's um
it's actually in the report um
1.9 agriculture includes horticulture
fruit growing seed growing dairy farming
the breeding and keeping of livestock
including any creature kept for the food
wool skins or fur
for its purpose in the farming of the
land the use of land is grazing land
meadowland oyster land market gardens
and nursery grounds and the use of land
for woodlands where that uses
ancillary to the farming of the land for
other agricultural purposes and
agricultural should be construed
accordingly um with regards to your
point regarding landscape so i've just
um put up this photo and um i refer to
councillor hackett's statement so the
issue is that actually the site is
i appreciate its screen uh locally
however you can see all the way down to
saunton in the in the very distance
and from a landscape point of view it is
very prominent
if you put four large structures there
at night for example if they're all lit
up they are quite clearly going to be
very visible in comparison to
what the site is now um so
hopefully that's answered your points
any questions i'm happy to answer them
council lock yeah
um because of my mind but oh and i think
we've discussed this on several plans
committee and i'm sure i could remember
other than saying
or even reading in inspectors appeals
decision
but um an application doesn't have to
fit
all parts of the policy you know if
you've got age
a to say k in a policy it can fit only a
few
i was not under the impression that i
had to fit all the categories because
i'm sure we've done that in the past
thank you i agree with that rose yeah
i'm sorry just to come in there
um no that is incorrect so you can't
pick and choose
from the policy it has to con in order
to consider
consistent decision-making it has to
comply with the appoi
with the policy in its entirety the
um alternative scenario wherever uh
sorry counselor lock may be coming from
um it might be that one policy itself
might be slightly contradictory to
another policy
and in that scenario they would only
have to comply with one policy however
the policy itself
you cannot pick and choose from that
policy it has to comply with the
entirety of that policy
sean
thank you chair um yeah just to comment
further on that
uh i think policies i think that council
lock probably considering are the ones
actually clearly state or
between the sections as opposed to dm15
which doesn't state or between the
sections
having said that as i mentioned
earlier on uh we can't consider any
other material considerations
and that is open to committee to do so
um
so whilst the if committee considered a
pro proposal
um doesn't necessarily record fully with
dm15
if committee consider there are other
material considerations with this
particular
scheme which are uniquely scheme um and
it could be so that committee
uh would uh want to support the scheme
provided of course we have conditions
which we may want to discuss later
on the basis that it fulfills the
policies st 13
as council like previous said without
repeating previous uh council locks
previous
motion i think the officers
viewed all that it doesn't uh accord
fully with dm15 i would like to say
there may be other material
considerations that members want to
discuss
to support the application thank you
thank you uh thank you sean well i'll
i'll just make a comment here on
st07 which is one of our strategic
policies which is spatial development
strategy
for northern devon's rural area now this
application
would not comply with everything that's
written there but where it does comply
for me is at brackets four of that which
says
in the countryside beyond local centers
villages and rural settlements so this
is like the open countryside which
chris christian eva says this is
development would be limited to that
which is enabled
to meet local economic and social needs
re rural building reuse and this is the
bit i've highlighted and development
which is necessarily
necessarily restricted to a countryside
location
for me this is an agricultural holding
in a farm i believe this is a farm
and i think this is diversification of
that farm
and i certainly think it it does
it it is something that is needed to
to support the activity of this
agricultural holding
which has got this woodland which is for
harvesting
if they wanted to harvest it um
and all they want to do to help support
this business this agricultural business
is to put these four lodges on the site
that they propose
and for that reason i'm and i've read it
very carefully i've read the policies
through
and i i do think we've got to
i'm going to support this application
its support is also provided for rural
employment and formal
root and farm and rural business
diversification schemes
rural business diversification schemes
this is what this does
um and farm dm-15 which is the farm
diversification
that little a bracket say the scale of
developments justified
by the operational needs of the
enterprise and will reinforce the
viability
of the existing farm business which is
this
forestry business uh
the leisure use you bring in the leisure
use because
those woodlands are leisure use in the
woodlands
it doesn't have to be swings and
roundabouts and buckets and spades
in the countryside where you've got this
type of an enterprise
is a leisure facility open to the public
to be able to use it
and i think we've got to be supporting
that type of development
and it does say about any new buildings
cited close to existing buildings well
defined close is 400 meters close
it's closer than a mile isn't it you
know what is
definition of close
it can be satisfactorily assimilated
into the surrounding countryside which
it can
and having regard to the forum bolton
design landform landscaping
and special landscape quality and
character
i mean just think it fits him with an
equine development i would
i would quote dm-16 as well
equine development justified new
buildings
or or ancillary development is well
related to existing buildings well
you can't really stick lodges and i did
see that they had permission
for four lodges some years ago actually
in the yard
where the stabling and horses are well
that's not really ideal for holiday
lodges whereas this site definitely is
right for holiday lodges in the area and
for those people who like to come down
and don't want
bucket and spade holidays but want
somewhere of quality to stay
where they can take enjoy the
countryside
you know we're all right we're lucky
down here we are lucky down here that we
live in this wonderful area
people who live in big towns and cities
they
yearn to get down into the countryside
and experience it down here
and this enterprise is exactly what's on
offer
and i do think uh and tourism and
leisure attractions well
visit dm17 visitor or leisure facilities
for me this is a leisure attraction this
woodland
it definitely is so i'll shut up there
for the moment
uh and i see sean wants to come back in
and then comes with a lot
uh thank you chair um if if the chair is
happy
uh given where the discussions are going
um
would members uh like some advice on
potential conditions that would be
required if lee mata were to be
supported by
by committee that would be very helpful
sanctuary
so in relation to the development in
front of us
the conditions that members would wish
to consider would be
the standard time condition a
standard plans condition uh we would be
looking for a condition in relation to
net gain to ensure there's net gain from
development
the standard holiday occupancy condition
for the lodges to ensure that lodges
aren't occupied permanently
yeah members may wish to consider the
removal of future
permitted development from the lodges to
prevent them being extended
and without the control of the local
planning authority
we would require details regarding the
resurfacing of the access track
uh to ensure that's appropriate members
may also wish to consider
uh lighting uh in particular um no
lighting within the woodland
um or on the access tracks and that
really that would be to protect bats in
other ecology
potentially um and also
a further condition could be considered
uh to protect
dark sky nighttime visual impact
and members would also wish to consider
a condition regarded tree and hedgerow
protection
um especially with regard to uh fencing
during construction periods
um so the uh the members may wish to
consider
whether that forms part of the original
motion like a chair
thanks for that sean i think everybody
would agree with with what you've just
said actually i
i was thinking about the holiday
accommodation uh condition
uh and the dark skies similar to the
a lighting scheme for these lodges would
need to be submitted in my view
that um just specify what type of
lighting i think we had
a similar condition on that one down at
heartland at the last minute
to do with lighting and that is
necessary but
counsel a lot do you come back a minute
sean before i
bring cancer rocking yes sorry thank you
chair um i was also uh going to add
that if members were to go down that
route then the word the final wording of
that
of those conditions could be dedicated
to officers in conjunction with the
chair and vice chair
thanks sean councillor locke yeah um
i thank sean for all his advice on
those conditions i'd just like to read
our mbpf 84
plan and policies and decisions should
recognize that sites to meet local
business and community needs in rural
areas
may have to be found adjacent to or
beyond existing settlements
and in locations that are not well
served by public transport
in these circumstances it will be
important to ensure
that development is sensitive to its
surroundings which this one does
does not have an unacceptable impact on
local roads
which it doesn't and exploits any
opportunities to make a location
more sustainable which this one does so
i definitely think mppf
84 applies but i do agree with all the
suggested conditions that shawn has put
before us
so i would still know that the
application is approved on those grounds
thank you council not councillor watson
yeah yeah
here again she's done it again so yeah i
totally agree
with what rose is saying and and yes
sean um
all those conditions would be totally
acceptable to me
i i think you've could have covered it
really great um
so yeah i mean i i'll i'm going for it
okay
thank you councilman watson right well
there's nobody else got their hand up
but again under dm17 as well at 13.105
tourism leisure attractions it does say
a rural environment eg
farm park or historic and historic
landscape
or those needing to be located within an
area of woodland
and this is where where i've been
considering this application it is a
it is a tourism application really and
i do think it fits in with our policies
not
not necessarily every single jotten
thing but then again these policies can
be interpreted
in in various ways and i do appreciate
that christian evelyn the officer
presenting this and sean harrington have
given us their full
their full uh explanation of the
policies and
and that but it is it has been
proposed that this by cancer look that
this has approved
this application it's been seconded by
council
watson was it the golf chair
it so council watson did you want to add
yeah i i i i'd just like to agree with
you there chris on
on on dm17 i was going to bring that up
actually
uh uh dm 17 part two
it states in there when when you read it
elsewhere within the undeveloped coast
of blah blah blah development
of new or the expansion of
rationalization of
of existing there is the word new in
there
so that means you new new and you know
new lodges new um
buildings all together yeah i i think
dm17 fits in with this as well part two
thanks councillor watson again i'd
highlighted that
dm17 brackets due development of new ad
highly
lighted where it says visit
visitor or leisure facilities will be
supported where and then it goes up to
its plane
so sean and then i'm going to go to the
vote with this
yeah thank you chair i don't want to
prolong this any further than we've had
with discussions
um but just mentioned about dm17 is in
relation to
attractions um as opposed to
tourism accommodation which is
considered on the dm18
so this is your leisure attractions um
you know
your um sort of parks and things like
that as opposed to actual accommodation
but i'll just leave that there and you
can go to the vote
i was only making the point sean that
for me this is a leisure attraction
these woodlands
are definitely a leisure attraction they
are their
leisure use chris
hi councillor and before we vote can we
just make sure that we've got a reason
for approval
um usually in an officer report we don't
need a reason however because
you'd be going against officer
recommendation you would need
um to have a reason for approval um
which you would then vote upon i think
what you're saying about
uh i'd completely take your points about
dm17 and dm18
cheers thank you
uh counselor lock um
do you want to put you your reason
that it fits it was policy sd13 and the
two dms that um chris quoted just now
and mppf 83
mbpf 84 subject to all the conditions
that
sean harrington listed
okay thank you council a lot and i still
stuck in that chair
thank you councilman mcgough
right i think we'll go to the vote on
this one there then
yeah i need a couple takers
i think we've thrashed it well and good
and we've been through all the policies
that we have considered uh
so let's go to the vote mary could you
take the vote now please
it's because for approval
council about him for
council brown or
cancer christie
councillor craigie or
cancellata or
cancel a lock or
thank you that's unanimous chad thank
you mary thank you for that
sean that's with those conditions that
you've mentioned
jack can i just go and have a make a cup
of tea
no oh thanks very much you can have
a comfort break for two minutes well i
only want to make a cup of tea
no we can't leave meetings for that
move on then without counsellor watson
making a cup of tea
okay
right our next application
is application one oblique zero four
double eight
twenty twenty outline application this
one was called in
i believe by councillor james
um and j
james jackson you're giving this
presentation i believe on this one
that's correct thank you chair and good
morning good morning members good
morning members of the public
um as you as the slide in front of you
suggest this is item eight b
this is application one slash zero four
double eight slash twenty twenty slash
out
it's an outline application for the
erection of one uh dwelling with all
matters reserved
uh and the site is land adjoining sunny
view milton dameron
holdsworthy and in terms of your agenda
this is on pages
19-28 here we see the site
location plan on the left hand side the
site is outlined
in red there with the additional land
within the ownership of the applicant
set out in blue we can see that there's
an existing dwelling to the north of the
site to the test site for the site the
two barns with extant planning
permission
for their conversion to two dwellings to
the east of the site we've got the
public highway
and the access there to that highway to
the west of the site we have
agricultural parcels of land and the
site was
formerly an agricultural paddock
which did use to accommodate some
dilapidated agricultural buildings that
have now
been removed
could you just go back one slide please
chris
thank you on the right hand side we've
just got the aerial image which just
shows the
kind of linear form of development along
the two highways which meet
within the centre of the hamlet um the
majority of development is along
that highway fronting onto the highway
and we can see from the surrounding
context that that is
a predominantly rarer character
next slide please thank you this slide
just shows the
a bit of a wider context really what
we've got here is where the red arrow is
that's the site
um above that we've got a yellow
triangle which denotes the location of
the
um milton damer parish hall over on the
left hand side of that slide
with the blue circle is the blackberry
farm shop also known as lizzy's larder
which is a relatively well stocked
convenience store
and towards the center of the slide
within milton town we've got two
places of worship next slide please
this is proposed indicative site planner
sections
indicative because the application is
made in outline form with all matters
reserved
uh here we can see on the left the site
plan just shows us
indicative purposes the single dwelling
located within the centre of the site it
shows that that can be accommodated on
the site with a parking and turning area
uh soak away drainage and the right hand
side are some indicative sections um
which essentially just show that the
the land is slightly higher on its
northern edge and then drops away
slightly to the tank
next slide please
uh here's some photographs the one on
the left-hand side is taken looking
uh west from the public highway that's
through the existing
access which is shared with the um two
barns that have the accident permission
uh from conversion to dwellings uh
the shot on the right and stood just
inside that gateway there
looking up to the north and the um
existing dwelling
that borders the site next slide please
uh on the left-hand side here we're
standing within the site looking west
this is the concrete pad that's uh the
remains of one of the dilapidated
agricultural buildings that has now been
removed uh
this photograph on the right hand side
is looking south
through the site at the two former
agricultural barns that are planning
permission for conversion
next slide please
on the left hand side there's a
photograph taken at the western boundary
looking west
there's an existing field access at that
part of the site
it should be noted as well there is a
further access
to these agricultural parcels
which is located up by the the parish
hall
and the right hand photograph is taken
from the western boundary looking back
through the site towards
towards the public highway essentially
and down on the right hand side of that
photograph you can see again those two
former
agricultural barns and next slide please
the material considerations in this
instance are principle of development
character and appearance residential
amenity biodiversity
highways farming surface water drainage
for the reasons set out in your office's
report the application is
uh recommended for refusal thank you
chair
thank you james well we've got one
speaker
for this application that's councillor
ken
james who's the ward member um
right thank you chair thank you
committee and there's no time limit on
you counselor
no i should i should be my usual thing
and be very brief and i deal with
common sense rather than all the
technicalities
it's a job to know what to say to
justify the psychos i think the officer
having just shown
everything um about where it is and what
he said
it almost proves the fact that it is a
site
that is worthy of development um but we
have not got a five-year plan
the site is within the easy walking
distance of a
community um facility it is
um i've seen the somewhere it did
describe it as a paddock but i think it
is a redundant paddock
um so it is a bromfield site it's
surrounded by
property you've got the barns on the
left where
it's got a shared access that they have
been granted
permission for conversion to dwellings
um
whereas i've got to be honest and say
looking at them i'm not so sure
about that um it's fully supported by
the
uh the local parish council um
and really i'm not going to go and alter
the technicalities about
development in rural areas you know that
well know that i'm
very strongly concerned about how we're
dealing with development
in rural areas and the previous um one
you've just discussed
illustrates one of the problems we have
where
we are not looking at the economy or
providing homes in the rural areas
so i would just like to the committee to
give it serious consideration
and um that's really i think that's
all i want to say um it is an infill
site
amongst 20 other houses um there was
just one
i should just clarify um i've been
dealing with the owners of the site
there was some confusion originally
uh because the name on the inferior as
an agent
who i have dealt with many years ago as
a member of the hosin property trust
but my only connection with this has
been the owners
which is piper's um the building
um supplies company that is just up the
road
and actually live next door to one
member lives next door to the
site that's all i'm going to say chair
thank you very much for your time
thanks councillor james right that uh
that concludes speaking on this james
jackson the planning officer
james yeah thank you chad um i don't
don't want to sort of go lay the point
too much here but just to come back on a
couple of those points
that were raised by cancer james it is
absolutely correct that the council
cannot don't uh currently demonstrate a
five-year housing
land supply um the the impact of that
obviously
has set out within the mppf is that we
have to undertake the tilted balance um
as set out in your offices report so
that has been
and taken account um and just in terms
of the
uh easy walking distance to the um the
sort of local facilities i think
just having that slide in front of you
sort of demonstrates that
the the local shop is just over a mile
away
uh a long unless and unpaved um footwear
so in your office's view that wouldn't
be
um wouldn't qualify as an easy walkable
destination
so just those two points really thank
you jeff thank you james
uh who would like to start the debate on
this one
anybody nope
oh cancel the lock i was going to start
but you can carry on counseling a lot
i was waiting to see if anyone else
would
um i could never get my head around the
term
open countryside i mean driving around
the countryside i don't know when this
term came into plan and speak
but i mean if it was i don't know how
many years ago but if it applied now no
one
at all would be allowed to live in the
countryside and all the existing houses
i don't know what would happen to them
i do agree with um what the grand novel
said just now i don't agree with uh
council ken james
that liz's lard is an easy walk
i mean uh i was out for a drive on
sunday and we found the site and we
drove all around
and it would be a very hard one-mile
walk to strawberry fields liz's larder
but then all the other houses around and
there are 20 or 22 houses
they've all got the same problem so
they've all got to use their cars
um and going back to these houses
there's some old cottages there's some
more modern houses and bungalows
um and i've also agreed with council
james that it would be infinite because
if those
two bombs were um
they've got planned admission if they
were developed then it would you know be
incident and on page 25 if the officer
states the proposal is considered to
have called
with policies st04 dm04
and dm08a so
he's giving us some policies there to
approve the application
so i'll leave it there for the time
being thanks council a lot
councillor craigie
thanks chair um i i feel the same as
counselor lock i feel
um we need to have houses in the
countryside
and i really go by what the local people
think if
if the local people had thought that
this was
wrong then i would support them but
they're not objecting to it so it is in
phil
um there are facilities you could cycle
to the shop
i think we've all got to learn to cycle
um
and i i just i can't see
i i agree with councillor lock about the
open countryside
um what is what is wrong with people
living in villages
this is this is what the area you know
this is our area isn't it
it's beautiful countryside people would
like to live there
and as long as it doesn't stick out like
a sore thumb as long as it fits in with
the character of the village
i have no objection to it thank you
thank you council craigie uh james
jackson you want to come back
yeah thank you chair um i just thought
it'd be useful probably at this stage
just to set out the
um the glossary definition of
countryside which is set out in the
adopted local planks that just probably
i think help sort of things go forward
and countryside is is defined as the
area beyond
a development boundaries as identified
on the policies map
and b the principal built form and sites
allocated for development in defined
settlements without development
boundaries and rural settlements so
i it's obviously accepted within the
report that this site is within a
cluster of
existing development ie the hamlet but
by virtue of that
glossary definition it does forward in
the countryside
um i'd just like to pick up on a point
as well made by
councillor craig i understand that
there's no local objection to this and
that the parish council support it
but just coming back to a point really
as per the previous application
um the the requirement is to determine
the applications in accordance with the
development plan unless the material
considerations
indicate otherwise so that obviously
does require
um consideration of the proposal in the
context of the policies of the
development plan
thank you james councillor christie
thank you yes i'd just like to come back
in the open countryside thing because
um i have heard members of this
committee put forward some pretty
tenuous arguments
uh saying oh it's not the open
countryside when clearly
applications have been in the open
countryside but this one i think is
different because
i looked at it and it's clearly a hamlet
and it clearly is an infill
site um and i can't really see what the
problem is here because i wouldn't
classify this as open countryside myself
so i'd vote in favor of this one thank
you closer christy
well james
james thanks thank you jess sorry to
come back once again just
in terms of cancer christie's point i
just have to reiterate really the
glossary definition of
countryside that is that that is the
defined um
concept of the countryside um and so
it's i understand it's an infield
plot or what we consider is an infield
plot the the local plan
you don't have an infill um policy um
and so that could be relied on in this
instance okay thank you jeff
thank you thanks james well i'll have my
say on it
i like to hope and i do believe that we
on this planet's committee bring the
modicum of common sense to their
decisions
and it seems to be in short supply in
life these days common sense does
so members will remember at the top of
rally hill in northern
three dwellings new dwellings stuck out
on a limb
surrounded by three fields but because
it had joined the development boundary
of biddeford
it was being recommended to approve and
they were approved
um this is definitely a small hamlet
it's not stuck in the middle of a field
of network and for me when you look at
st07 the spatial development strategy
for north dams rural areas it does speak
their
little bracket small brackets for
in the countryside beyond local centers
villages and rural settlements
development will be limited to that
which is enabled to meet
local economic and social needs and i
think this meets that
criteria because it's to support the
local
rural economy in that area that this
infill site should be developed for one
small dwelling which is all that will be
in there and it's not going to affect
anybody
it's got local support and
i'm going to move approval on it for
that reason because i think it supports
the local economy
the issue about the roads in the area
well crikey all over northern devon
we've got roads that people either cycle
walk or drive along
everybody in the rural areas needs some
form of transport
um but i i think this does this one
dwelling would support the local economy
of the area
sean harrington wants to come in
uh thank you chair um yes i think
members will get a bit bored of me yeah
coming in and talk about the legalities
of decision making but
that's what i'm here to do so that's
what i carry on and do
um you will notice on the committee
report at page 26
at item seven uh the officer has made
the recommendation based on tilted
balance
um in the conclusion now as
councillor james and the officer
correctly said uh the party
don't have a five-year housing land
supply and as such the tilted balance is
engaged
now the weight of the different elements
put within section seven of the
um of the report is for the decision
maker
your professional officer's
recommendation is as per the report
but of course that weight could uh be
amended as for
a member's perspective and members may
wish to consider that waiting
i got from the discussion that members
consider latter is well related to an
existing group of dwellings which may
weigh in favor of members
discussions and of course as highlighted
in
section 7 paragraph 78 of the npps
does relate to rural housing in this
type of location
which members may also wish to consider
so just to conclude chair
um the the weighting of these elements
need to be considered
and that is for the decision maker i.e
um the plans committee
to consider that waiting and come to
conclusion many thanks
thanks for that sean thank you well on
page 26
the fell surface farrell and surface
water drainage
i'd highlighted however in this instance
given the modest scale of development
and the outline form of the application
with all matters reserved
it's considered that this issue could be
addressed by a suitably worded
pre-commencement condition that's on
that
and at the top of page 27 i've
highlighted highlighted that
in addition to the dwelling proposed it
could make a positive contribution
to the viability of the nearby local
shop and parish hall
as highlighted by paragraph 78 of the
nppf
there would also be a modest benefit to
a small-scale developer
and other trades persons resulting from
the construction period
as well as further modest benefit from
the payment of the council tax
i had a biodiversity net gain at the
site
would also be modest a modest benefit
it's also noted that the parish council
supports the proposal and no objections
have been received
from members of public so this tinted
tilted balance that shaw's
just spoken of comes into play i think
with this
and that tilted balance for me does tilt
in favor of approving this application
it is an outline application so all
matters are reserved
does anybody want the second my
recommendation to approve this
i'll second it thank you councillor
watson
does anybody want to speak to this
application james
you want to come back in yes thank you
chad
um it seems an appropriate time probably
as you were just touching on the
potential conditions there if members
were
um to find that this proposal was
acceptable and moved to grant planning
commission
um i would suggest that all of them
would be fairly standard
um we would just need a condition in
terms of the approval of reserve matters
at a later date
a time limit condition uh a plans list
condition that the
development shall be undertaken in
accordance with the plans i would also
suggest
a limit on the construction works times
just given the proximity of existing
dwellings to the site
also a standard condition requiring
biodiversity net gain which for a site
like this would just be
the installation of a bird or bat box on
the dwelling
also content just a condition the
standard one about contaminated land
and also just the detailed design of
foul water drainage so
um if if members were happy with those
conditions in terms of going forward
um then they could obviously be uh with
with members authority to be drafted by
um officers uh in conjunction with the
chair of vice chair
thank you chair thank you james
councillor watson
yeah james could could we put the
two-year rule on instead of three
i was going to suggest that
yes chair that would be fine no problem
right that's fine
i'll go with that if it's two years two
years yet
to get the reserve matters in yeah
lovely thanks for that right and well
nobody else wants to speak on this
application
so mary could you take the vote it's
been recommended by myself for approval
with councillor what's the second thing
yeah council about him uh for
cancer brown or
cancer christie or
cancer craigie or
cancellata cancel a lock
or councillor mcguff
or council watson
council wiseman oh
it's unanimous thank you mary
right we move on to our third and final
application this morning
which was called him by councillor
ford is the apple door one is uh
ithaca where he rode appledore and i
think
debbie debbie you're to present this
application please
hi good morning councillors good morning
holy debbie
um i need to provide a verbal update on
uh to the report on page 32.
the um the 2016
planning application isn't extant it was
never
implemented but it was approved so it is
a material consideration
but i've put in there that it's extent
and it isn't
it was never implemented
sorry chair we're just having some
technical issues if you just break us
for a second
this is what i said at the start people
have to be patient with us
these things do a carol can you see me
now
yeah we can see okay okay so the the
presentation before you is for um the
demolition
and replacement of bungalow uh in
torridge road apple door
with a two-story dwelling
next slide please so the location
in apple door is the west of ecuador um
ursha street the conservation area is
about 50 meters
north of where that red circle is on the
plan
um next slide please
so this is the site plan um it shows
um a larger dwelling than than the
existing bungalow um
new steps are to be
created and
balcony at the front and decking at
first floor level
at the rear and new boundary treatment
on westbrook which is on the
west west side
and privacy screenings next slide please
chris
these are the elevations there's the
front elevation and rear elevation
next slide
and side elevations and you can see the
original
dwelling in the dotted line there
so you can see on that slide sorry
privacy screens on both
sides and the two meter high fence
on the westbrook side and an obscured
glazed window
on the southeast elevation as well
so the height of the dwelling is no more
than the existing
it is a different scale um
obviously but it is the same scale as
westbrook which is adjacent
it's no further forward than high tides
which is on the east side
next slide please
there's a picture of the bungalow
uh high tides and two rivers in the
background
next slide please
and there's a view from the rear garden
obviously
this dwelling will take advantage of the
views the estuary
the garden is quite steep at the rear
so the first floor decking will be
coming out where the existing eaves are
now
to give access into the rear garden
at the moment it's it's very steep
um so it's cooled in um
next slide please sorry
was called in for um
by councillor ford for um concerns about
uh overlooking or possible overlooking
to westbrook
um and it being out of keeping
so this is the boundary with westbrook
and as you can see there's existing
overlooking
um and i don't think the proposal makes
that situation any worse
so if we can move forward to the next
slide
this is the view from high tides and two
rivers looking back at the dwelling
and there'll be a privacy screen and
obscured window on that side
next slide please
um the agent has hopefully provided some
perspectives
as part of the application um which
shows what it would look like in the
street
next slide please and the
some perspectives of the boundary
treatment this is on the westbrook
side and you see the privacy screen and
the two meter high fence
next slide please
and that's the eastern boundary
with two rivers
showing the privacy screen there next
slide please
so material considerations outlined in
the
report principal development
it's supported it's in the main center
of ecuador
existing urban area design and
appearance
i've talked about already there's a
mixture of
dwellings in the street all different
scale
flat roofs pitch roofs dormers
different materials it's 50 meters from
the conservation area
in terms of residual immunity i've
discussed that boundary treatment
and access and parking there's no
changes there's an existing garage at
the front
with a space in front of that garage
providing
two spaces for the dwelling
in terms of ecology there is a wildlife
report
and survey that's been submitted and no
bats
or nesting birds were found um and
in terms of enhancement they are
it's conditioned on the um
on the on the decision notice that a bat
and bird box will be provided and in
terms of drainage the existing
system is to be used so there'll be no
additional surface water
so my recommendation is to approve
with the relevant conditions
thank you lovely thank you thank you
debbie for that presentation
councillor craig before i've got three
public speakers to this do you want to
make a comment
no i'll wait till after the speeches
thank you
all right okay councillor craig you you
can lead the debate on this one then
right we've got three uh public speakers
to this and the first one
is wendy braxton who's speaking against
the application
and i see that you are here wendy
braxton so if you'd like to unmute
yourself
you have three minutes to present your
case
against the application please thank you
um i say uh wendy braxton my husband and
i
we live at westbrook which has been
pointed out
is next door to the proposed development
and i'd like to firstly say thank you
for letting us have the opportunity
to speak this morning and we have
strongly objected to both the initial
proposal
and the subsequent amendments and
these have been recorded in the agenda
notes
to the committee and our stance on all
of these objections
has not changed
however the reason for us attending
today
is to respectfully ask the committee
that if you were minded to grant
commission
that we consider three conditions
and firstly there is there is
confusion over the proposed fencing
along our boundary with ithaca
and there's discrepancy between the
drawings the annotations on the drawings
and the graphics in the proposal
for both the height and the location of
the fence
if if the committee could make it clear
that the two meter fence was speed
was to be erected for the whole of the
boundary and that this is measured from
the ground level on
our side of the boundary this this would
give a more
consistent boundary and would soften the
impact
of the white wall of render that you can
see in the picture
that's still up on the screen it would
alleviate some of the privacy issues
and secondly the works will undoubtedly
take some time given the the size of the
property and the
extremely restrictive access and
they're going to impact the traffic flow
along torridge road
which is the main route out of the
village to the north
the works will certainly occur over the
spring summer months when traffic is at
its busiest
so if the committee were minded to limit
the building works to say
ninety or five week days only this would
still leave
the mornings the evenings and weekends
for residents and visitors
to travel freely for work and school and
and enjoy
a noise and dust free time outside in
the lighter and warmer months
and the third point is that torridge
road as has been mentioned
is actually on a steep slope and all of
the houses have considerable retaining
walls etcetera
but we are concerned about the impact
the proposed building works will have on
our homes current construction
we understand that the proposal is to
demolish
the single garage and use this as access
to the site
the picture that's still up on the
screen you can see the white garage
there
and our garage is adjacent to that
um we believe that our boundary wall is
the dividing wall
between the two garages and they both
share a continuous roof
and in addition the new foundations to
the extension
will be just over a meter away a meter
away
from our own retaining walls so we would
be significantly reassured
if the committee required an appropriate
insurance policy to be taken out in
joint
names of the property owners and
ourselves to cover any damage to our
property
and i would absolutely stress these
don't mean that we're changing our
objections
thank you for allowing me to speak i
understand it's protocol that there's no
discussion backwards and forwards so i
have actually emailed
a copy of these over to the committee
thank you wendy braxton and our first
speaker
in support of the application are dave
and lindsey inwood they are the
applicants
and there's a statement that they've
given to sean to read out
sean if you'd like to read out that
statement
uh thank you chair um yes so starting
the statement
hello to the planning committee and
thank you for the opportunity to support
our application today
we are david and lindsey inwood and
ithaca will be our permanent home for
the foreseeable future
we want to settle down and be part of
the community in appledore
having fallen for the village enjoyed
the welcome we have received
the house has been unoccupied since 2015
we believe
despite some earlier cosmetic work it is
small damp draughty
and really unusable as a holiday home
whilst just the two of us will live
there full time the house needs to be
large enough for visiting friends and
family
most importantly our little
grandchildren we have been living on a
sailing boat since 2009
and are passionate about having a small
environmental footprint
our main goal in developing ethica is to
create a net zero carbon home
meaning it will use zero fossil fuels
and generate as much electricity as it
uses
to achieve this it will be super
insulated and triple glazed
aiming to achieve achieve near passive
house performance
with mvhr and ashb the flat roof allows
enough solar panels to be orientated to
provide
all the power the houses uses over an
average year
we are also solving problems with the
site's immunity
the current approach is very steep and
unsafe for little ones and the elderly
so new steps will improve accessibility
for everyone
the rear garden is raised several metres
above the ground floor and is currently
hard to access
by moving the living accommodation to
the first floor and using decking to
link across
the rear garden becomes readily usable
before buying we researched other
developments in the area and in
particular
1-084-2016 ful
which was permitted something large and
intrusive
we considered a relationship of our
house to its site to minimize the impact
on others whilst achieving our
objectives
the house presents a small increase in
bulk when seen from the road by
offsetting the new structure
to the side and rear we have avoided any
new overlooking of rejection properties
race structures the rear of neighboring
westbrook already overlooked their fence
into our rear aspect and garden
whilst we can't eliminate this
pre-existing problem
our development proposes high fencing
and screens to improve our privacy and
that of our neighbours
we hope you agree with us that this is
an exciting development that creates a
sophisticated building that showcases
future energy standards
and does not intrude on others thank you
thank you sean uh right the next speaker
we've got
in favor is caroline short speaking in
favor she
she is the agent so caroline short if
you'd like to present
to the committee please okay morning
members thank you for um
taking this time to consider this and
yeah my name is caroline short i'm the
director of park architects and we're
the agent for the proposal
um i tried david and lindsay's um
statement kind of repeated quite a lot
of what i was going to say about the um
about the proposal
being um highly sustainable and looking
to be near zero carbon with high levels
of insulation and air tightness and that
was
one of the driving parts of the brief
and from them as clients was
was to have as low a carbon footprint as
possible and i said that has been
um very highly considered as part of the
design
and i think um a lot of the objections
some of the objections were to do with
the
i think the scale and massing and of the
proposal so i'll just look to address
those
and so impairing the proposals we look
to respect the scale of the existing
property
and and also that of its direct
neighbors and westbrook
to the west and high tides to the east
and
so we've kept the um the ridge the
height of the building lower than both
of those and
the massing is similar in scale also and
we analyzed during the design process
we did analyze the street scene and
which um as debbie had said is they've
got a really eclectic mix of
architectural styles there's not really
a dominant style in the street
so we felt that something that kind of
high quality contemporary would actually
be quite
fitting here wouldn't look out of place
on in this location
and we've kept the external mate against
materials was raised and so we've kept
the external
materials we wanted to keep them light
the existing building is white render
we've looked to keep a similar kind of
light appearance we've looked to use
again we wanted to use
sustainable materials in the development
so we'd look to use large which can be
sourced locally and for the first floor
and that's kind of to break up the
massing of the
of the scale and then the scale of the
building and
we've so so while the
um while the whether the proposal is
larger than the existing house
it's not it's not really dominant
because it sits quite a lot as
you've probably seen from the photos it
sits quite a large way back it's about
seven meters back from
from the street and and we've also then
looked to keep
it within at least a minimum of a meter
from the
boundaries to the neighbors to and
prevent any kind of overbearing
on them um and so the need to respect
the immunity and privacy and to prevent
overlooking
was taken into account and it's part of
what we do as designers is something
that we're always considering as we're
designing so
we've tried to to minimize that and
and so we have we did um have a little
bit of correspondence with the
with the with the owners of um of
westbrook
and following that we did reduce the
length of the um
length of the building a little bit to
reduce the gable on their side so to
reduce the kind of
the size of the wall like that that is
on their side of the um
of the property and then we've added the
privacy screen and obviously as
being said and looking to look at how we
can make sure that all of the fencing is
at that two meter height
and i think and the applicants won't
have a problem with obviously working
with best book to make sure that they're
they are happy with the various heights
of old fencing um
so yes and the current approach is is
very steep so we're looking to improve
that
one of the objections raised was a
concern about the retaining wall
we have actually and the applicants have
got the appointed the same structural
engineer that that
designed the front retaining walls
they've appointed him
and and he's happy with the proposals
that there won't be any adverse um
structural impact
on that and obviously that is a big
consideration for the west brook
side as well so that is something
obviously that nobody wants to have to
and
to deal with is undermining any
retaining structures so that is
something that obviously will
will be dealt with through the process
um then i think the other objection was
there was something mentioned also about
the flat roof and this was something
that we looked at again we looked at
various
forms for the roof um during the design
process and we did 3d studies of that
and because the building it sits quite
back far back from the street when we
did actually
put a pitched roof in it because it runs
parallel with the
with the road and it's so sorry it's so
elevated that kind of four meters above
the street
you hardly really saw it so it didn't
really add anything and actually
the gain of having the flat roof and
being able to kind of to maximize the pv
array
and the benefits that that will bring we
thought what would justify
the fact that it has a flat roof
now please yes i think yes so to
summarize um
the applicants and ourselves that we're
committed to producing a really high
quality new home that will be an asset
to the street scene
and um and hopefully enhance the overall
quality of the building environment in
apple door so thank you
thank you open to the committee for
discussion and consideration now
councillor craig
thanks chair um
i really welcome the fact that it's
going to be carbon neutral
and and all the effort that's been put
into that
but when i look at it i'm afraid i just
feel that it's an over
development of the site it's not even
i mean i don't like the look of it but i
know that that
is just a purely subjective opinion
but um i just don't think it fits into
the character of the area
it doesn't even match their new
buildings that are next door to it
um i i just feel it it looks overbearing
and
especially for the people who live next
door that large
white wall must be fairly overbearing
and then the overlooking um
i don't want to discourage people from
being for doing carbon neutral homes
and all being modern or being innovative
but i
just feel that in this particular
instant it's the wrong house in the in
that location that's all thank you
anybody else like to add to the debate
on it
uh councillor watson yeah thanks jeff
yeah i
i i i actually disagree with
councillor gregory i think it's i think
it's a good design
uh as you i've been up and down that
street quite a bit
and there's all sorts of um
all sorts of different style properties
down there
and i i don't think this sticks out at
all i think it's
very sensible it's carbon neutral
yeah um i think it's a i think they've
done a good job in designing this to be
quite honest
um so long as they stick by you know and
look after the neighbors
and stick you make sure that their or
their property is okay
um i'm quite happy to to propose this
thank you councillor watson councillor
locke
yeah i listen to what the objector said
um
and would it be possible if it was
approved that we can condition that the
two meters fence
goes along the whole of the boundary of
the properties
so that does make sense in my opinion um
with regard to the construction
condition i see it's on page 37
condition number four yeah um
would it be possible to take out
saturdays and just have construction
monday to fridays
because someone said i mean i've driven
down torrey drove lots of time
and in the summer it's almost impossible
on a saturday because holiday changeover
so i would even last saturday when i
drove down because that other house has
been
constructed further up on the left-hand
side there was vehicles there
so i would like to see that condition
change just monday to friday if that's
possible
yeah um and she also mentions insurance
but of course that is a civil matter
so i um if those two conditions or one
could be added and one could be changed
i would support the application
thank you thank you council lock
councillor christy
yeah thank you um
council craig does raise an interesting
point because it
it does look fairly alien to the rest of
appledore i have to say
um ecuador is an old fishing village i
know there's been lots of modern
buildings there but they are fairly
traditional looking
uh i can see the reason why they want
this and uh
i think the arguments in favor probably
do outweigh the arguments against but
um i did have a a phone call from um
councillor ford
uh who called this in um it was at eight
o'clock this morning
um asking me it was actually about point
four uh
the time he does point out some of the
problems are getting down this road and
i think we all know those but um he did
ask uh
could it be stipulated the the lorries
uh delivering aren't there uh
while the school bus is coming through
because apparently
um when one of the nearby houses was
being developed
not long ago um one of the delivery
lorries managed to block the road and
the school bus couldn't get through on
an exam
on an exam day and the students were
as you can imagine getting fairly upset
um
so he did ask could that be included in
any
time limit because of the
problems of this road which we're all
aware of
thank you councillor christy sean sean
harrington
uh thank you chair um i'll just jump in
um
and the case officer may want to uh
correct anything i say or add anything
extra um in relation to the
uh time condition members will be aware
earlier on this year from updates from
the government in relation to
coronavirus and construction times
where the government advised that uh
local plant authorities should be
seeking extending construction times to
9 pm
at night now there is a caveat in that
in that
we still have discretion as a local
authority um to refuse that or to reduce
that time
frame as you'll note from the officer
report the condition
states seven o'clock i suppose nine
o'clock taking that into account
but it would still be in the discretion
of the plans committee to reduce that
further to 5 pm
if they felt that there was unacceptable
immunity impacts
to surrounding areas in relation
to councillor christie or councillor
ford via council christie's
um comment about construction traffic
and
schools that could form part of a
construction management plan
and we could also include a condition
requiring a construction management plan
that would detail
that type of element also things like
wheel washing and
wider implications of the construction
period
again to protect neighboring immunity
and
the the use of lee highway
finally and i think this will find one
on my list council locke's comment in
relation to a condition about the fence
that becomes slightly more difficult
because a offense could be considered
permitted development
um whilst i think we could word a
condition that would meet the test
um in relation to two meter fence um
that would likely be two meter from the
uh ground level that fences erected on
as per the permitted development
allowance for fence
and i note that the objector
made mention of the height being from
the ground level on their side of the
property
of course we have no details of that so
i'm not convinced that that would be
um a reasonable condition many thanks
chair
thank you sean anybody else like to make
comment
well well i'll i'll have my say on it
when i saw this one i've been called in
by councillor ford
uh principally i think for overlooking
and also out of keeping with the area
i along with some of the other councils
who've spoken on this one did
think well there is a wide range of
styles along
torres road there um and it's a
subjective thing whether
one likes a particular design or not but
i do know
and i'll print it i printed off all the
plans and
have looked at them very carefully
principally because of the overlooking
but the height
the height of the dwelling is no more
than that ridge of the bungalow that's
there currently
and it is larger in that it moves closer
to westbrook
than the bungalow that's there now but
it does not move any further forward
on that site so the the overlooking
issue i think it's non-existent to the
front
because the bungalow currently has
dormant window
that bungalow currently has dormant
windows in the roof which look out over
the front
so i don't think overlooking to the
front's an issue and i don't think
when you look at the side elevations
towards westbrook
there'll be an issue of overlooking to
the side i take the point
about using the first floor for the the
bedrooms down below and the first floor
used
for the living accommodation with a uh
a balcony out onto the another balcony
an area out to level go level with the
garden at the back
and of course that's a reason for those
privacy screens on either side
but when you look at westbrook too when
we had the virtual site visit and again
this morning
the the garden room that westbrook has
up at the back of the garden
that really does overlook into the back
of the current bungalow that's there
um that one there i mean that really
does overlook into the
into this site currently but if this
fence
is proposed to go up through there that
would cut that
overlooking issue down for this
site and also the other way around
looking over into
westbrook's side um
and i take the point that sean said
about two meter fencing we
we can't stipulate that not knowing what
the ground level's like on
we can only consider this site that we
know about um
i think nine nine o'clock until five for
construction
you can't expect building workers not to
work to start work until nine o'clock
but i do think uh taking the point that
councillor christie rose raised about
school bus
i think time deliveries of materials
to the site should be between nine
o'clock in the morning and three in the
afternoon
and i think we can condition that so rgb
or juices or whoever they buy the
building materials off because i went
along there there a couple of weeks back
and there's a lorry with its hiab crane
unloading bags and
loads of timber and there was a huge
amount of traffic
queuing up both ways it was blocked the
road completely so i think
time delivery of the building materials
should be stipulated
and i should think nine o'clock in the
morning school buses have gone by then
three o'clock in the afternoon that's
probably before the school bus comes
back
and i think we ought to put that in as a
condition
and i'll set an approval on it sure
council watson moved to approving our
second approval with that condition sean
if you'd like to come back on those
couple of points yeah no that's fine
chad
what you say can we just um delegate to
the wording of that condition uh to
officers um
in conjunction with the chair and vice
chair fine yeah
but we can condition time deliveries and
materials can't we
yeah i think that'd be reasonable and
given the highway impacts in that area
lovely thank you right unless anybody
else
wants to make any comment uh or i'll
just mention because uh
wendy brackstone did mention the garage
and i look the plans i've seen that the
garage is staying there
so i don't think that's going to be an
issue it's not not proposed
to demolish the garage so i don't think
that's going to be an issue
counselor lock yeah um just with regard
to
the construction um word in
are you going to take the saturdays out
altogether or do you want saturdays left
in there
i don't think you can take those out to
be honest don't you take the saturdays
out
and there's no school bus on the
saturdays i know it's busy with tourism
tourists in the in the
summer but saturday is a very busy day
for a lot of building workers
right but i i really don't think you can
restrict that too much
no my view anyway i don't know what sean
says to that
uh i would agree because we're already
restricting it further to the government
guidance on construction hours
due to coronavirus which was um the idea
that was to help with social distancing
for
um construction workers so we're already
a lot lower got to hours than that
government guidance
so to go that step for everyone on
saturday i don't think would be
reasonable
okay no that's true okay mary it's been
moved
to approve and seconded could you take
the rules on it please
yes chair cancel about him oh yeah four
councillor brown four
council christie
council craigie against
council leather or
councillor lock yeah
councilman mcgough four
council watson
council wiseman four
now that's eight four one against thank
you mary
we'll move on then that's the left
that's the end of the planning
applications this morning
we move on to item 9 on the agenda which
are the appeal decisions on pages
40-51 um
i'd remember looking at that one
actually that's been allowed
uh the other two the one that stabbed
cross and one at higher cleveland been
dismissed
and you've got the the appeal decisions
are there so we'll move on from those
nobody wants to comment on those
to agenda item 10 which is
costs you see there's one application
there which was refused
and item
11 is delegated hmb applications on page
54.
um all of those four have been approved
agender item 12 of the planning
decisions on pages 55 to 65.
i'll start with the pages numbers at the
bottom 55.
oh council lock i'm waiting for a page
number to come out i was ready
waiting page 55
page 56
page 57
page 58
page 59 page 60.
yeah page sixty six one down
conversion redundant outfield to provide
over spill accommodation to main
dwelling
i've never seen those words over spill
accommodation
i mean is that private residential or
holiday does or is that
that apply to both i've never seen
overspill accommodation before
sean would you like to make comment on
that it's interesting that isn't it
it's not an annex is it then yeah
yeah um i don't know the details of this
particular application
i assume the over spill came from the
application form
which was actually applied for i can
provide
committee members with further details
of what that actually was in relation
once i get back to the office i can uh
review that permission
all right thanks sean uh page 61
oh sean you got your hand up
no apologies that's a legacy hand legacy
page 62
863
h64 um
oh that one i've had some a refused one
direction of the dwelling land adjacent
to 96 bayview
northern i've had quite a lengthy
letter from from somebody couldn't
understand why that one was refused
and i've looked at it and i got a
feeling it may be resubmitted in any
event that one but there we are
okay unless anybody else has anything
from page 65
not development nope thank you
all right well there are no um
i have no need to exclude the public
council a lot you wanted to
had some well just before you closed the
meeting
um just a general point of interest i
had reason
to join west edinburgh council plans
committee meeting last week on
youtube and they used the skype platform
um they were 50 were nearly 20 minutes
late
starting because they had so much
internet troubles
and then they did an interesting thing
they
when they come to vote on an application
they have to say
i have been present throughout and heard
all the information
regarding this application and then they
say for or against
so i don't know if that was something we
could add for members of the public to
know that we've sat through
all the presentation no councilwise
not in his head or shaking his head i
just thought that might be a way forward
yeah i think um tom will answer this
question he
tom can answer this i think i'm correct
in saying that on youtube
and we're still live on youtube uh
people who are watching on youtube only
see
the speaker is that correct that's
correct yeah
or whoever's speaking at the time is the
only person that's
shown on youtube that is great yeah
yeah so it might be something we can
consider once the
i've closed the meeting don't leave
because there might be a few things
to say after we've closed so i will
close the
the meeting now officially out
where it's 11 11 33
and thank you to those who have watched
on youtube this morning i hope you found
it interesting
and the debates that we've had over the
the particularly the first two well all
three of them actually
but um thank you for viewing those of
you that have
uh and i hope you've you have been
interested in what you've heard
so goodbye